Let's go through these together.
This is well-formed HTML, we're beginning the bold tag.
It ends after the word "really." This looks great.
Unfortunately, in this next sentence we end the bold before we start it,
and then we start it over here with Eric Blair.
That's not going to work out well. I will show you in just a minute what that looks like.
Here, we begin the bold tag and then we have lots of space and then the word "really."
It turns out that is totally fine.
Web browsers use the same sort of techniques we talked about in the last unit
to break up sentences like these into words based on white space.
All this extra space doesn't matter.
Finally, down here we start bold at the beginning of the sentence,
so all the of these words--George-Orwell-was-really-Eric-Blair"--
they're all bolded. Notably "really" was bolded as well, so this works out.
Let's go see how this plays out.
Here we have the first option--"George Orwell was really Eric Blair"--
and really is definitely bolded.
If I reverse these, it's harder to interpret.
This bold tag closes nothing. It's ill-balanced. This makes me super unhappy.
But this next one applies to "Eric Blair," and then falls off into the end of the universe.
This isn't very good.
I can put huge numbers of spaces here, and as we see,
this does not influence the rendered web page at all.
Then in this version I have the tags at the start and the end of the sentence,
and the whole sentence is bolded.
George Orwell is perhaps best known for writing 1984,
and I hear that HTML has always been at war with JavaScript.